no matter how much they love that woman  and no matter how many mortgage payments  they pay they are going to cheat and  with women a lot of times it's the same  way now a woman will will rationalize it  will say oh well you weren't  communicating with me enough or or you  know I'm not happy anymore or you're  neglecting me uh they'll come up with a  lot of reasons but at the end of the day  you know it's very difficult for a woman  for a man to really ascertain the exact  reason why his particular woman cheated  but you know it's certainly based on  personality it's also based on  circumstance if your wife has a work  husband oh  I hope your man has a work wife yeah